hi hi public interviewers hi
you want to be interviewed we asked the
public in London their opinion on
certain topics
hi what's your name
Ellie do you have any social media you
want to plug no no it's fine yeah so
today's topic her body her choice right
do you sense women have the right not to
be mothers if they don't want to should
men have the right not to be fathers if
they don't want to
yes in in for example um
I'm not sure how her body her choice
um what's the connection here that's
about abortion well let's leave that
aside women have the right to give up
the child for adoption yes and yes that
is mentioned absolutely at the same
right to give up the child for adoption
um because that would be really like for
like we talk about the rights I don't
think to draw parallel between abortion
and and men not being fathers but
certainly if you're talking about giving
up the child's adoption or disavowing
yeah then men should have the same right
as women and women do have that right
why don't you think it's comparable
abortion and
um child support abortion is a different
question
um
it's whether the woman has a right to
abort the child or not I mean even if
you might you might agree that a woman
has the right not to have to physically
support
um with her body I mean physically
obviously everything would do is
physically but I mean you might agree
the woman doesn't need to physically
um give life to the child and yet you
would still think that the woman should
have to feed a child if the child is
born and vice versa he could think that
the woman shouldn't be able to kill the
child because it's it's a human being
and yet you could still support the
right of the woman or the man to give
her the child for adoption said I don't
think he can I mean he can he can be on
one side of one argument on the other
side the other arguments basically are
you are you pro-life
um yes that's I'd say broadly speaking
yes do you think it should be illegal
all of the time
um probably the best argument could be
made for for when it was non-consensual
to begin with I think the best argument
for adoption for abortion is that um
with a famous argument that you know you
imagine you wake up someone's done
operation and you've been hooked up to
another person it might be the certain
Nobel Prize scientist and your kidney is
supporting him and if you unplug
yourself from him or hurt um what
percent of abortions do you think are um
in the case of rubber incest or grape
grape YouTube I have no idea it's
actually less than one percent okay fine
I'm saying that I'm saying broadly
speaking I'm pro-life because uh I think
there is a there is a there is another
life and certainly there shouldn't be I
can all this way I'm not going to run
away with it if you want to mean it's
easier okay
um certainly there shouldn't be an
option of aborting just because
um in the same way in fact in the same
way the argument is often made if you
ever go in any forums for example study
feminist forums but even not necessarily
feminist forums you'd say their fathers
don't want to support called deadbeats
and really maligned and they thought
look if you don't want to have a child
then either you know wear a condom or
abstain tie your um have the snip all
these things all these arguments and the
same could be applied for women if you
don't if what you you want to be certain
that you're not going to become pregnant
and you know um have to support the the
child when it's born the life you know
give give support life support to this
child then don't have sex but and it's
interesting because 40 of abortions the
woman has had two or more abortions and
it doesn't track if they have an
abortion in the future
so only 60 of abortions are their first
time and it doesn't track what they're
doing in the future so it seems like
it's becoming a form of contraception
rather than a worst case scenario
I'm not sure what you want I mean that
wasn't the question today no I was just
telling you this staff I was just
wanting to get your reaction to it okay
it's interesting I I mean I'll take your
stats at face value I'll have to believe
you because um just check that but even
voicing it's it's hardly a formal
contraception generally speaking you get
the morning after pill they're much
easier ways of contraception even after
the fact saying it's being used as a
form of contraception like rather that
like when I I a lot of people think like
it should be a last case Resort and
right now we're seeing it being used as
a form of contraception and you can see
that because 40 of women are keep
getting them over and over again and
that doesn't include women that have
them in the future
what do you mean a form of contraception
why would they why would they have an
abortion why not just for example either
beyond the pill use a condom or take the
morning after pill so I agree that's how
it should be but that's just not what
they're doing it's because it's legal
and free yeah but no I think you're not
getting what I'm saying I'm saying it
does make sense that women are just
using it because legal free so just
using it why not because it's much more
difficult for the person in order to
have an abortion usually we're talking
about we're talking about six eight ten
twelve weeks even and they've they've
had to carry that they've had to be
pregnant for 12 weeks already which is
more difficult hard on the body so it's
hard to believe that it's as simplistic
as you're putting it that just using its
contraception there must be something
more to it a reason why they're not
aborting or using the morning after pill
straight away or what's happening what's
changing but he's probably a bit more
complex than I mean I can't tell you why
I'm just telling you what the data says
right it so I don't know why they're not
using contraception but like it's it's
self-reported so they ask women how many
abortions they've had before and that's
what they write down
you were saying why but that's the thing
you were saying why you the data is that
women are having multiple abortions and
your analysis was that it seemed and
then you added it seemed that they're
using it as a form of contraception well
yeah because that's that's literally
what they're doing if if they keep
getting abortions over and over again
it's a form of contraception yes to a
degree but I'm saying it's probably a
bit more complex but what do you what do
you think I don't know I don't have to
think whatever I think would be just a
theory and that need to be backed up I
mean like you can Allah you could give a
guess why something is the way it is but
often it's just my bias your bias all of
our biases uh informing us why we make
these analyzes but um really should be
backed by by evidence say overall in
pro-life anyway because uh and so it's
often portrayed as a you want to punish
one women for having sex and it's not
that at all it's having sex carries the
known risk of becoming pregnant so if
you engage in activity that you know
might end up with you having to look
after the
I mean really the the real question is
always when does Life Begin and and
that is also uh I mean I say personally
I'm pro-life but I they're both sides of
the argument so the one side the
argument is that it's pro-life it's a
human life what then would he call it I
mean aborting means killing it's killing
a baby an unborn child you leave it's
going to grow and 95 of a ball by 95 of
biologists would agree that it's light
yeah so of course it's life yeah but the
question is he that is their own
question a question isn't when does Life
Begin it's it's when personal begins
um I.E human rights um when do we call
it a person so we give it it's entitled
to all the rights and protections and
that's not not clear-cut because there
is no definitive answer I mean there's
no knocker argument you say it has to
begin at conception DNA or or whatever
there's no real reason you can always
argue different the whether it's a
heartbeat whether it's birth whether
it's um
what's that I forgot the word where the
fields and you know what I'm mean when I
can feel pain
I forgot the word like brain activity
brain activity also um well I forgot the
words when when it feels when it feels
pain it's the way people differentiate
between insects and and animals they are
not sentients oh yeah yeah
um so again but this so the real
question is when should personhood begin
I said there's no definitive there's no
science nobody could really answer that
from from any reasons it's all emotive
um
it's one thing I wanted to ask you about
I just slit my hands oh yeah um let me
ask you can I because
IVF
what what's your opinion in general
oh I don't know enough about IVF to
really have an opinion on it
IVF uh you've got you get eggs
fertilized in the laboratory and then
um usually might be 10 12 eggs and the
most viable one or two would be then
implanted into the woman all the others
are discarded
and I know some and I have no idea
whether you're Christian or not to watch
like from where you're approaching it
but certainly you know some Christian
groups are very opposed to IDF to IVF
sorry because they
um they claim that this is uh the ones
that are discarded there's really a
discarding life it's akin to abortion so
all the 10 fertilized eggs that don't
make it that aren't implanted are then
discarded so that's the same as aborting
yeah I don't really have an opinion on
it
um no I'm not with like a Christian
organization or anything I just have a
YouTube channel okay what is that what
what's your channel oh just probably
there pearly things yeah just curly
things but thank you for sitting down I
appreciate it thank you very much